from sports illustrated a columnist as
well as a man who's been covering
college
sports for quite some time pat 40 back
on the show how are you pat
hey i'm all right rich uh happy big 10
football to you i i appreciate that
i guess uh interestingly enough we we
that was the reason why we have you on
but i do want to put a pin in that for
the moment and talk about lsu
that that broke the minute uh we had
actually booked you to be on the show
today
um and you are part of uh the report uh
talking about what is going on in lsu
that did
in fact uh lead to an odell beckham he's
the the the biggest name
i guess uh outside of the current
program involved with it
i give you the floor on what's going on
with lsu
uh it's messy and it's interesting
you know none of these are new
allegations per se but we now are seeing
what lsu is trying to do to get ahead of
a potential mushroom cloud
situation you know they're they're
offering some self-imposed sanctions
including disassociating odell beckham
as you said
i mean certainly one of the most
high-profile alums they have
uh because he as we all know
like i was wondering if this is the
first time we've ever had like major
violations just play out in real time
right in front of the media
it's like what are we doing seeing here
when he was paying players
uh in the superdome right there after
the game uh
that the much larger violation
a booster funneled 180 000
in stolen money to the father of a
player
for a no-show job and so basically
they've got these football violations
but they've also got this really big
basketball investigation going on
the ncaa wants to wrap them all into one
big investigation
and then most likely have the leverage
to charge this school with lack of
institutional control because basically
you've got two different sports that are
committing major violations
lsu is fighting very hard to avoid that
happening
i'm not sure who's going to win but so
far it's advantaged the end to the ncaa
because
they have referred the case uh up the
ladder for
for hearing purposes uh and
so far the the allegations are bundled
together
will it affect any play this season or
this is just for another day it's just a
fascinating headline
um that involves odell beckham and cash
that we saw that went viral on twitter
him actually pressing
cold hard american cash into the palms
of of collegiate athletes in front of
cameras
does this manifest itself in any way
this year do you think pat
i don't think so no no uh you know these
kind of things
as of course one of the biggest problems
with ncaa justice is it takes forever
and lsu doesn't even have a notice of
allegations yet
pertaining to the basketball stuff so
you know i would say we will be
lucky if we are reaching a resolution to
this
at this time next year pat 40 here
on the rich eisen show let's get into
big ten play um
right here right now um clearly the ohio
state
uh is the school that with the best
chance to join whatever college football
playoff that is held
uh is there any issue with that going in
the fact that they're
joining late that other conferences have
already played
uh where does that issue stand before we
even see a snap of big ten football this
weekend
pat you know i think if you look at the
landscape it's
it's begging for some more quality teams
so i don't think at this moment it would
hurt
ohio state or penn state or michigan or
minnesota or wisconsin whatever turns
out to be the best team in that league
i think if you look around you see
alabama
you see clemson and then there's a gap
and as we all know it's not a two-team
playoff it's a four-team playoff so
i think there's it's wide open
opportunity for somebody to impress from
the
the big ten and kind of changed the uh
the the landscape there the only
uh complication that i see
rich is we've seen i mean
teams are postponing games teams are
canceling games games are being lost
roughly 10.6
i believe of the game so far have either
been postponed or cancelled
and the big 10 has no room for any of
those because they have no five weeks no
off weeks to move anything back to
so if you start canceling games there if
one team
loses two games now okay you're looking
at a seven game schedule
is that enough compared to a 10 or 11
game schedule for someone else
that could be where they get into a
disparity just in number of games played
that could
hold the big ten back in terms of
playoff resume and then in terms of the
schedule
you want to can you explain to everybody
what that final week is where
it's kind of everyone from one
conference plays somebody from the uh
from one division play someone from the
other division to try and figure out
eventually who is the champion who could
be forwarded
as this is our best team for the college
football playoff
to uh consider because there's no big
ten championship game
pat it's basically an east-west jamboree
of sorts i guess you would say but you
know the number one team from the east
plays the number one team from the west
the number two team from the east plays
the number two team from the west
number three versus number three and so
on
you know and some frozen field that will
be watched by approximately eight people
uh but you know it's a nice idea gives
everybody one more game and yeah it
could give one more quality game to the
top two teams and since there's not a
lot of cross-division play
in this setup uh it should provide you
know a chance for whoever that best team
is in the west to get their shot at the
best team at the east you know
presumptively that's ohio state
and that is presumptively ohio state
unless um
i got to tell you man just for a moment
for me here pat
um this uh fella joe milton um
has me fascinated uh absolutely
fascinated
i mean he he's six five or six six which
wherever you read about this michigan
quarterback he's the first quarterback
that jim harbaugh is going to be
starting
to start a season that he actually
recruited himself
out of high school um and he's 240. i
mean he
is a large human playing this position
that could be
potentially transformative unless i'm
just uh
jumping to the uh conclusions here pat
i'll give you the floor to tell me
what's what
well yeah a lot of hype um coming in
about joe milton
as you mentioned just the physical size
he's almost cam newton's size maybe ben
roethlisberger kind of size i mean he's
a big big guy this supposedly can really
throw it
hey it has the ability to run it as well
uh
you know it's easy able to step in and
give them the quarterback play that
quite frankly they have not had under
jim harbaugh one of the reasons he was
brought in is because he had done such a
great job
coaching quarterbacks throughout his
career whether it was with the 49ers or
whether it was at stanford
uh and so you know can can he finally
get that quarterback position
cranked up to a higher level uh than it
has been quite frankly the
the pass efficiency numbers under him
have been worse than they were under
brady hope
so that that is not good that's not
where you want it to be
and if you're trying to chase ohio state
with justin fields and with the
cutting edge offense they have and
you're trying to keep up with
or get into the same category with
clemson with trevor lawrence with
alabama with their quarterback and their
receivers you you have to be able to
match points to a degree in modern
college
football and uh michigan that hadn't
been their their ability
uh in years we'll see if they can down
so uh
are there any big ten teams that are
allowing fans in to stadiums best you
can tell
i know i i believe there's a
conference-wide uh
agreement that no fans other than family
of uh
of athletes and coaches that's it okay
so there's not like gonna be any
any and i guess dan mullen moments and
in terms of that
um when do we think florida's gonna play
football again pat
well we'll see i think you know i think
what their virus numbers look like this
next week
um you know i guess on monday probably
would the
official cut bait time for the halloween
game
um which i think is against missouri but
i mean they've missed two
if they have to miss another game i mean
then you start actually losing games you
get the point where the big ten is where
they they've already used their buy
weeks and they're
they're moving around flexibility on the
schedule
so i mean it's a mess for for florida as
we
you know found out i mean the numbers
are big 31 positive players i believe it
was and with contact tracing
who knows how many are possibly affected
or in quarantine
uh i'm not sure how long it's going to
take for them to get it back together
and
and when we'll see for it again so they
dan mullen
uh said something stupid and then it
came back as
even karmically worse with what's
happened with his program no doubt about
that and i hope everybody is well and
safe and certainly the kids don't have
any any lingering effects pat 40 here on
the rich eisen show a few minutes left
with the
senior writer from sports illustrated so
uh who who has the best chance
to beat the ohio state in big ten play
do you think
oh boy you know i mean probably penn
state although
you know losing micah parsons who's
probably going to be like a top 10 pick
at linebacker
and then journey brown they're running
back he's most likely out for the season
you you lose those two things and and
that's those are losses you can't really
afford when you're trying to match up
with the most talented team in the
in the conference then you know i think
it's michigan minnesota is a heck of a
game here
this first weekend i'm very bullish on
minnesota uh they lost a lot of defense
got to replace some big players there
but boy their offense should be very
good again
rashad bateman opted back in great
receiver tanner morgan quarterback was
very underrated last year the whole
offensive line is back
i think the winner of that game has won
a really
high quality game and will be uh will be
able to take a big step forward in terms
of who can compete with ohio
state last one uh from uh from the next
level pat uh from the nfl
uh the conversation is uh tanking for
trevor
uh already been going on uh for pretty
much
a couple years i think as soon as well
as soon as he started running away from
ohio state players
last year i think that was the the
ceiling of the deal of certain teams
just saying this kid is particularly
special
and we're already hearing conversation
bill cower said publicly roddy white
added to the mix that
trevor lawrence should stay in school
rather than run the risk of becoming the
next sam darnold
because of the jets what are you hearing
about trevor lawrence's thoughts on this
subject if at all
pat well i mean he already said this one
he wants this to be his last year um you
know i don't know whether yes he had
fully
uh reckoned with the specter of being
the jets quarterback
but i would expect him he's still going
to go
uh he's certainly ready and you know
maybe he tries to
to go the eli manning john elway route
of
you can draft me but you need to trade
me uh or you need to trade the pick
uh and and try to end up somewhere else
i i don't know i don't you know have any
insight into
his mindset he is he's one of those guys
i mean he comes across great in terms of
coachable
team great attitude about the game
so i don't know how high maintenance he
would be in that situation but it might
be a matter of where
you sign with an agent your agent says
look this is what we need to do here and
you let the agent be the bad guy
but uh it's going to be really
interesting to see yes how if
if the jets end up you know continuing
just as catastrophically as they have
been
and then how trevor lawrence feels about
wearing the green so
uh the the concept of trevor lawrence
staying for another year would be news
to you
dabo swinney anybody else pretty much if
there is some sort of reversal of you
know what i think i'm going to stay put
that would be news big time correct
absolutely
yeah and i mean he loved his time there
he could have opted out this year you
know very easily but
he wants to be there he wants to play
he's an absolute competitor
um so it's not out of the question you
know that he might say
i'll just do another year there but i
just i think that you you're looking at
the
the at your financial future and saying
you know any risk of huge injury that
you could take a 100 million 200 million
dollar career and
and and jeopardize it just because
you're kind of worried about playing for
the jets i i don't see that happening
neither do i and how about to a man i
figure i'll just give you the
the the floor here uh him being named uh
kind of out of the blue uh in a way
named the starting quarterback of the
miami dolphins and
you know setting up an incredible uh
game that we wouldn't be
normally talking about cincinnati uh
taking on miami in week 13.
it sounds like it would be set for a
saturday on cbs with the sec instead
it's going to be set for a sunday on cbs
uh in the afc um i'll give you the floor
on
who tua is and what he might have shown
uh behind the scenes to make this
maneuver
um quicker do you think pat yeah i mean
he's a wonderful soul i mean just a
delightful
young man a great attitude enjoys the
game
has fun playing uh never seen him
feel like a situation is too big for him
you know he i mean he he truly believes
he is good enough to do whatever you ask
him to do including
to take over from a guy who had done a
pretty good job and done pretty well for
his team i mean that's the surprising
thing to me rich is you know the
dolphins
aren't owen 405 and then out of the
contention or anything they're doing
well and to make the change now well
that
that certainly says they like what they
have seen from tua
a great touch on the ball wonderful
accuracy
and and one thing saban always said
about him is instinctually
gifted of players he's ever seen he just
has great instincts for what to do and
when
how about that and herbert's doing
really well too i mean that's no
surprise right i mean he's
he's um he's been terrific for the
charges so far
pat yeah he's he's actually surprised me
a little bit because
i mean he had all the physical talents i
just wasn't sure he was accurate enough
and i thought enough big games where he
would kind of get a little wobbly
uh but he's been he's been really good
so far
very good okay so before i let you go uh
alabama clemson and fill in the other
two blanks
as we're sitting here uh prior to the
big ten season
what do you think alabama clemson
ohio state and
i'm gonna say i'm going to say a second
sec team
maybe georgia you know i
i i didn't love what i saw out of
georgia on saturday against
uh against alabama but they're still a
high quality team they've played a bad
second half there but that's that's who
i'll throw in for the fourth
is there any chance to pack 12 when they
come back can throw their hat in that
ring
pat sure because yeah because the the
spot's open
basically i mean like i'm pretty tepid
about georgia i think the rest of the
nation is too
at this point so yeah if oregon or usc
or
arizona state even jumps up and has a
really good season yes the pac-12 is
is viable pat thanks for the time
appreciate it let's uh let's check in in
a
couple of weeks and uh talk now we we
might have a power five back in uh in
the mix it sure looks like it's gonna
happen we're knocking on wood thanks for
the call
all right thank you richard you got pat
40 at pat
pi by pat 40.